e aí a hora de assistir o canal junto
com vocês como está tudo bem bom tem
pouquinho bom por muito tempo eu evitei
fazer esse tipo de vídeo primeiro que eu
nunca me achei a se uma pessoa é a
artista famoso em que porque as pessoas
quererem saber alguma coisa a pessoa
porque ela é alguma coisa nunca me achei
assim essas coisas na plataforma de bi e
talvez de hoje vai ser sobre cinco
coisas que vocês não sabiam sobre mim
sem vocês querem saber mães primeira
coisa que você não deve saber sobre mim
eu toco há mais de 12 anos o que os
punha não conhecia já foi muito muito
mais tempo eu toco vários instrumentos
eu toco violão contrabaixo guitarra toca
um pouco de sanfona e
hum
ae
eu vou pagar pra bem
amorim ainda a segunda coisa que você
não sabe sobre mim eu atiro em você a
tiro em seu artigo para matar a criança
papada mingau terceira coisa que você
sabe sobre mim antes de fazer vídeo
youtube era garçom eu comecei a
trabalhar com 15 anos de idade que eu
queria ter um celular ea minha mãe
infelizmente não podia me dar um celular
é o que eu fazia e trabalhar de garçom
eu entrava sete horas da noite saiu às 5
horas da manhã pra ganhar 70 eu ficar só
por um bom tempo eu já até fazer vídeos
quando era garçom mas só vai pra estar
depois eu encerrei de cabeça enfiada na
cabeça bom caiu de cabeça nesse negócio
de outubro a única coisa que vocês não
sabem sobre mim eu já matei três
crianças que estavam brincando com o
apelido quando era criança era vela
branca exatamente vela de igreja branca
branca porque minha gente você não tem
noção de como esta pessoa que era branca
quando nasceu saibam albino tava pessoal
bin1 albin do meu lado era nem era
extremamente branca quando alguns homens
quando na rua e ainda fala e fala como é
branco deus milagre é o primeiro vídeo
que está no caminho oposto também tom
sabe que só de raiva e vou ficar é cecam
mesquita coisa que você não sabe sobre
mim eu já fui do mundo do crime é esse
rapaz que vocês vêem aqui agora já é
depois de uma reabilitação a conviver
com a sociedade normal porque eu já fui
no mundo do crime é difícil para você
acreditar mas é verdade eu ia sumir
quando eu tinha quatro anos de idade
robalinho supermercado verdade eu e meu
primo maio a estratégia é o seguinte
elenco é como duas formas crianças com
sede no mercado e chegava o seu rosto
falou se tem água o meu deus que
crianças
o meu deus não está atrelado com ela pra
vocês imprensa que eu vou lá e pega o
homem ia pegá lá né só que só que só que
o goleiro era daqueles que você tinha
que rodar para poder desembarcar e pegar
um negócio bem só que quando você rodar
e fazer assim o dono do supermercado que
tinha alguém querendo pegar barulho o
que a gente fazia um pedir a água volte
a ficar no ponto onde o homem trabalha
voltava ligeiro
eles buscavam emitia bom pegar o bahia
nós sair correndo mas ruins como é que
você chegava em casa com essas baleias
de você não percebíamos de você não tem
quintal de onde vêm essas balizas a mãe
de vocês atentado onde reside ou senão e
quem disse que não chegava em casa
meninos comeram tudo meio da rua na sua
cueca chega e marinho no meio da rua sem
ter nenhuma passava por ele jogava assim
e até a cabo via ruim porque você não
faz querer 50 faço meu amigo 50 fato é
que a noite houve 50 quando não há 50
fato não tenho nem 50 coisa interessante
para dar a vocês se você tiver bastasse
clean postei aqui no youtube caso você
tenha visto a seguir no facebook volte
lá e curta que você ia me ajudando muito
e se inscreve em um canal para cultivar
virou sem saber beleza muito obrigado a
ter que assistir vídeo até aqui não se
esqueça que tudo sabe e tudo ele é todo
sabe toda quarta tem vídeo novo que
nesse canal é só voltar de um saber
bater o varzim bem sup pinta se quiser
me seguir no twitter que a descrição do
vídeo game seguinte está no ataque na
descrição do vídeo querem seguir no meio
da rua e me siga com tanto medo muito
obrigada teve inter nos falando